look at the marin method and let's take a tip
today only the applications that you
do and have a new devices
A little problem happens, come on.
looking down here has a roof of a
menu that if you press for any
action type does not work
This is something that is not very cool.
which has new and
simply runs out of a menu and
may not even allow you to
be featured in prehistory
Let's see how to fix this very easy.
here in the eclipse is only you see that in your
manifest your project and always change
the kahvece team one for the most
new android
In this case today we go to 18 oc
you save your your project
then you can run it again here and
You'll see how it goes.
to disappear
this menu is okay and this is
very important because the application does not
look like an old captive in
new devices we will give a
look here we can see that the menu has disappeared
brings the captive is ready to go to the store
come on